greetings planet Houston I am General
Zod and may I wish you all a merry
zodmas
let us talk about another strange oddity
of your holiday snow on Krypton it does
not rain snow it trains the hut flaming
ashes of many a meteorite and an
occasional white drizzle of acid rain
and we don't play in it we die in it we
retreat to underground caves the few
children that go outside return without
any heads we call this Kryptonian
natural selection it made us feel proud
and strong and sometimes headless we do
not have the fun that you people have on
planet Houston we do not have snow cones
we drink enriched uranium slurries
they're terrible but they make us strong
and sometimes our heads grow back we do
not have sledding we say all the stars
in our weird little crystal cocoon
thingy where we are serenaded with the
sounds of our elders who are teaching us
boring school lessons for a thousand
years have you ever heard Kryptonian
economics 101 on audiobook not fun the
more I think about it maybe snow is a
trade up lord knows it's better than the
double-sided mirror of banishment all
right you can keep snow but I'm
confiscating all of the world's snow
cones the yummy and tasty and better
than uranium slurries and they're all
mine now that had a final sum up snow
approved and bring me all of your snow
cones for they shall have a place of
honor in the cydonia people's republic
of houston also known as the Z Poh or as
I like to call it super this is General
Zod and you will all kneel before me